this gets into the most famous rumor
about you with the whole penis thing did
they tell you on Mad Men
well let's address it for for once put
it on the record did you bring it first
yeah Robin wants to know if it's here or
did you leave it at home but John did
did they tell you on Mad Men you must
wear underwear that your penis is so
large that it is in fact interfering
with the performance and and it's I have
worn underwear every single day of my
life Howard that is so that's a rumor
that in other words none of that is yes
first of all who doesn't wear underwear
I yeah I've wear especially women every
day in my life
oh come on I love a comfy boxer brief
thank you very much good for you yes I
mean uh I'm proud of you like a
breathable I like a breathable cotton
come on man who doesn't John What About
Love what about Robin
when's that all gonna go down I mean
she's ready I mean could you ever commit
to one woman
yes be married you could be married
you've never been married right yes I've
never been married you could for sure
this is all part of what I'm saying like
this is another place in my life that I
feel very
settled and comfortable in I'm in a
relationship right now and it's it's
good Robin yeah thank you you could have
happened
uh
and and it's and it's and it's
comfortable it's a feeling about taking
care of someone else and being taken
care of and it's also been a process of
working on myself my mental health all
the stuff my therapist and
and unpacking all of that trauma and
realizing that you know when you lose
somebody like that's so important to you
like a mother
uh so early that that creates a wound
absolutely that blocks a lot of that
emotional accessibility that blocks a
lot of that uh availability and and
vulnerability
and it's only been in the last couple of
years me kind of sitting down and really
thinking about all that stuff that's
that's made the relationship that I'm in
now is even more meaningful and and
opened up the possibility of things like
being married having kids hope you know
defining a new version of
happiness life
Wellness all that stuff that's
it sounds hokey and whatever but it's
real and it and it's it's for one of a
better word it's it's what I'm working
for right it's what I right what else is
there other than that you know would you
like to announce now that you are
getting married to your longtime
girlfriend uh that would be a rating I
will not announce I will not announce
that now but I feel you're close I feel
you're in love
very much so am yeah you are declaring
your love right here
yes live on the air
wow sweet this is this is new this is
this is special this is big and uh I see
wedding bells and I I will I know what
you're thinking you want me to come
through here you hear wedding bells more
than seeing them but yeah oh that's
right I forgot you're right